That ends the introduction
to discriminative methods.
So we talked about that basically
the idea is that we're going to
build a representation and then
somehow we have to train a classifier
that's going to look at
the division of the boundary.
The simplest method we showed
was nearest neighbor or KNN.
Oh, I didn't say, would k of set of,
of say, mm, six be a good idea?
>> No.
>> No why not?
because how does it work?
You'd find nearest k and
you pick whichever one has the most.
Why are there nine
Supreme Court justices?
Because you don't want a decision to
come out four-four, if there were eight.
So k typically is odd, so
that you get, you always
a majority one way or the other.
All right.
In the next two lessons we'll talk about
some much more sophisticated methods,
and in particular,
their application to Computer Vision.